so on the channel we spend a lot of time
talking about communications theories
language use and the structure of ideas
so here's an opportunity to put all of
that theory into practice
contact your representatives now this is
advice that you'll find embedded in
every political call to action whenever
a journalist asks an activist what can
people do the top of the list is always
contact your representatives so this is
going to be a concrete overview of what
that means and how you should do it now
I'm going to try to make this
generalized for any legislative
democratic system but it will still be
ever so slightly slanted towards the
United States
owing to their recent turn of events
first what do you want always have a
clear goal your communication needs to
be focused and ask a specific question
and keep it contained one call one
subject if there's 20 things you want to
say get ready to write 20 letters what
you're really looking for is a strong
call to action that requires some kind
of feedback you are contacting your rep
and there is something you want can they
do it even when you're calling to
express general dissatisfaction you want
to structure it in a way that asks for a
direct response the reason for that is
when you get someone to formulate a
response you are getting them to come up
with verifiable claims promises or
statements of intent to which they
should be held accountable if you are
holding them to account then you're
asking them to reconcile promises with
reality and what you're actually looking
for is uncertainty a point where the
representatives platform is weak or
disconnected because that's a gap for
negotiation that's the path to saying
hey here's a better stronger more just
more moral more compassionate platform
here's the human impact the human cost
and here's what you can do about it
second what level of government are you
looking to contact this is going to have
a dramatic impact on your plan the more
local you aim your communications the
easier it is to get an ear there's a
couple of reasons for this the obvious
is that representative systems are
pyramid-shaped
the peep
towards the top represent a lot more
individuals than the people towards the
bottom so there's simply more people who
want their time tied to that the people
towards the top have a lot more power so
getting their attention has potentially
greater payoffs the more local you get
state or provincial municipality or
County the easier it is to get someone's
ear not to say it's a guarantee they're
still busy people being an alderman in a
midsize City is still a full-time job
but they and their assistants won't be
getting the same sheer volume of
communication that a congressman's
office will be but this is going to be
the biggest question to answer because
it's going to inform just about
everything about your strategy what
methods of communication do you use how
do you time it how is it structured do
you coordinate with others and so on
third have you done your research what
do you know about your representatives
in their stance on various subjects
what's their voting record look like now
a lot of this stuff might be online
available in summary from various
stakeholders like activist groups and
you should definitely check their
website or Twitter feed or Facebook for
some official platform but this is also
a perfectly valid thing to open up lines
of communications with especially for
phone calls it can be good practice
you're calling your representatives
office because you want to know how they
voted on a given bill and you're having
trouble finding it online or you read
their platform but some statements were
vague and you want clarification because
keep in mind that nothing will undermine
your communication faster than an angry
phone call where a staffer kindly
explains that representative Clark did
in fact vote no just the same as your
reps lose credibility when it's clear in
your eyes that they don't know what
they're talking about the same will
happen to you if it's obvious that you
haven't done your homework now generally
speaking you want to stick to your
representatives because staffers are
conditioned to discard contact from non
constituents out of hand but this isn't
a hard and fast rule as part of the
government representatives have
additional roles and responsibilities on
various committees and boards and if you
have a concern relevant to those roles
then yes you should contact them forth
what's the relationship like is it
adversarial this means that you don't
agree with their
politics you don't agree with their
policies or they're doing something and
you want them to do the opposite instead
the degree to which the relationship is
supportive or adversarial is huge
because the further you need to persuade
someone to move the greater and impact
you need to make and while we're here
contact your representatives doesn't
just mean convince them to oppose
something
it also means let them know if they're
doing a good job let them know you
support them and contact them to ask if
there's anything you can do to help
because if there is something you can do
to help if there's an open hearing you
can attend if there's a rally you can
volunteer for if there's a fund you can
donate to they're going to know that
also even if you know that the
relationship is probably adversarial
always open your communication lines
with the assumption that they're not
assume good faith if they're making poor
decisions then assume they made a
mistake or they were uninformed of the
consequences this is particularly
important when it comes to phone calls
and talking with their staff don't be
mean be firm be angry if you need to be
but don't be mean fifth what channels of
communication are you looking to use
ranked in order of impact the options
are face to face phone calls physical
mail email and social media physical
mail email and social media are all
text-based and they're all discretionary
meaning that the recipient can engage
with them at their own pace on their own
time and you can write them from home
proofread and really put a lot of work
into crafting a very tight message
social media is cheap it's instant and
it's public those attributes make it
useful but also make it popular meaning
that competition for attention for
mental bandwidth is very high social
media also tends to be poor
communicating long complex ideas this
has to do with user interfaces character
limits and the readers state of mind
while engaging with the service
basically the medium is the message so
with that in mind
social media tends to be best at
communicating overall tone rather than
specific ideas unless those ideas are
very simple and very short the main
strength of social media is the public
aspect building momentum getting others
to join in getting the attention of
media
creating public pressure email is also
cheap and instant but it's a lot better
suited to communicating longer ideas
than social media it's also really easy
to ignore and really easy to sort and
filter the busier in office is the more
inclined they're going to be to scan
emails for general subject and respond
with a form letter now physical mail in
many places elected representatives are
legally obligated to read every piece of
mail they get in practical terms that
usually means having their staff read it
for them and sum it up or select a few
exemplars but physical mail is still
incredibly valuable the only downsides
are that it's not instant it is
personally inconvenient and it isn't
free but here's the thing to keep in
mind and we're going to talk about phone
calls in a second which are super
powerful but there's a particular
strength of physical letters that
nothing else can match and it's the role
as a prop see politics is entirely about
persuasion whether that be through force
money rhetoric or reason when your
representatives go to the floor their
job is to try and persuade everyone else
in the room to agree with them which
means that there is a performative
aspect to their job think to yourself
how many times you've seen the clip of a
representative on the floor saying madam
Speaker Joe beer drinker from I rioting
wrote me this letter and in this letter
he says writing to your representatives
is literally an opportunity to put your
words into their mouths the value of
this is hard to overstate it's a chance
to have a direct impact on the way that
an issue is framed the language that is
used and the lens that it is projected
through think of how many issues today
from gender and sexuality to mental
health classism race that are defined
almost entirely by the language that
people use because that language sets
the frame how many damaging policies are
in place right now because of phrases
like boys will be boys contacting your
reps letters in particular is an
opportunity to shape language now as a
matter of protocol you always want to
prioritize the local office over the
federal office and this goes for phone
calls as well as phone calls are the
single most effective channel of
communication you have
without leaving your home unlike written
communication phone calls aren't
discretionary if you're on the phone
right now
their staff needs to talk to you right
now they can't skim your phone call four
subject and tone at 9 p.m. while
watching stranger things you have their
time right now again the reality is that
you're more likely to talk to their
staff than to them personally especially
at the federal level so the strategy the
game of persuasion that you're playing
is to impact the staff enough that the
message gets passed on clearly and
actionable and we'll come back to this
later when we talk about strategy now as
someone who hates making phone calls yes
they can be intimidating don't be
ashamed to practice with a friend first
to role play to make notes or even write
out your question or statement in
advance you want to make a human
connection but you don't want your
message to get lost or to be unclear
face-to-face meetings basically mean
town hall meetings and town hall
meetings are generally woefully under
attended by the same couple dozen people
every single time this is good news you
can be one of those couple dozen people
and if you show up with 4 5 10 20
friends if you all prepare your
questions beforehand you can be a block
that they can't ignore if you've ever
screamed at a TV interviewer who just
let a softball non-answer slide Town
Hall's are your chance to fix that
finally what's your strategy one of the
most valuable things you can do is get a
group together whether that means
coordinating with a bunch of friends to
send letters or phone calls at the same
time or joining an advocacy group and
coordinating with them the more voices
you can add together the more impactful
the message will be if you pack a
town-hall meeting then yes your issues
are going to be discussed if you tie up
their staff on the phone all day if that
becomes a day where nothing else got
done because they were answering calls
from constituents for six straight hours
yeah there's going to be follow-up now
with that though and this is going back
to letter-writing be careful with form
letters advocacy groups will typically
provide sample letters and sending a
form letter is better than sending
nothing but humans are built for pattern
recognition so there's a very fine line
here common language
like specific phrasing is a way to set
the way that your concerns are framed if
a staffer reads the same phrase over and
over again they're going to fall back on
that phrasing when they pass the message
along but if it's too similar if it's
clearly the exact same letter well then
it just gets added to the stack it
doesn't have the same impact as an
interjection I'm stressing the value of
acting as part of a group but don't ever
let the lack of a group stop you because
here's the thing being politically
active is a thing that happens over time
just because you don't have a group now
doesn't mean you won't have one two
months from now a year from now as you
do more research as you attend Town
Hall's as you meet other people but if
you never write a letter if you never
make a phone call if you never go to a
town hall if you never start researching
well let's just say it's unlikely that
you'll just stumble into it in the
future
activism is a skill and like any other
skill it's built over time so don't just
write or call once do it repeatedly even
if it's on the same issue if they're
refusing to answer a reasonable policy
question stick with it yes I'd like to
believe that most people have
representatives that are ultimately
rational and amenable to change but
there will be adversarial relationships
if not outright hostile ones but repeat
yourself if necessary don't worry about
being obnoxious or rather don't let the
fear that you will be perceived as
obnoxious stop you from writing or
calling to a point you do want to be a
thorn in their side because even when
the relationship is hostile volume
matters one of the other things that
should stand out at this point is the
importance of a representative staff
they are part of the inner circle they
feed ideas and words and materials
directly to them summarizing the vast
bulk of information that comes in every
day their job is to interface with the
constituency get to know them meet them
persuade them strategy should also take
a look at which levels of government you
want to focus on in an ideal world
everyone has the time and energy to
research contact and recontact their
municipal state and federal
representatives about every issue but
it's exhausting it's a lot of
information it's a lot of time it's a
lot of energy the advice here changes
a lot based on what the issue is that
you're concerned about so you want to
find the level where you can make the
most tangible impact with the energy
that you have available a lot of times
that energy is actually going to be
better directed a lot lower at the Civic
or state level rather than federal C
even if the federal government sets the
pace for policies surrounding say
policing it's the civic leaders who
actually meet with the police officers
who live and work in your neighborhoods
who tell the police chief's what the
citizens are saying it's a lot easier to
get your city to change how it views
mental health crises and whether 911
police or EMTs to those call than it is
to change the entire nation's stance and
that flows upwards local successes
become support for state programs state
successes become the case studies for
federal policy it's a slow grinding
process yes but it is possible so
contact your representatives thank you
for watching